vous êtes le député qui a marqué la
rentrée politique avec cette tribune
publiée dans Libération sur le projet de
loi immigration 10 jours après quel
résultat le coût de pression sur le
gouvernement a-t-il fonctionné au voisin
dans l'invitation signée ce soir par
Marco Polo
si on vous invite Sacha où y est c'est
parce que l'aile gauche de la majorité
se rebiffe et vous en êtes le porte-voix
en Une de Libération vous réclamez dans
une tribune avec d'autres personnalités
de la nupesse la régularisation des
sans-papiers dans les métiers en tension
l'initiative agace dans votre propre
camp et j'ai peur qu'on perde finalement
le message clé qu'on veut faire passer
qui est celui de la fermeté en
commençant par parler de régularisation
Sacha Houlier vous avez su vous rendre
un contournable aujourd'hui président de
la puissante commission des lois à
l’assemblée votre ascension est
fulgurante étudiant à l'esprit
contestataire vous multipliez les
actions durant vos études grève et
blocage contre le Contrat Première
Embauche contre aussi la réforme des
universités le message qui a été délivré
et qui a été bombé
surtout la rue Victor Hugo il est le
suivant c'est étudiant mobilisé contre
les rues contre la mastérisation contre
les suppressions de poste d'abord
militant socialiste tendance trop
scanienne le déclic s'étend 2015 Macron
boy de la première heure vous cofondez
le Mouvement des Jeunes avec Macron à
seulement 28 ans vous entrez à
l'Assemblée nationale vous devenez le
plus jeune vice-président de
l'institution chers collègues quand je
mets au vote un amendement c'est un
amendement quand je me vois ton article
c'est un article
ambitieux proche du président à la fois
loyal et têtu voilà comment la presse
vous qualifie vous la voit parfois
dissonante de la majorité abstention sur
la loi sécurité globale opposition à
l'application stop covid sur ces
questions d'éthique il y a toujours une
liberté de vote une liberté de
conscience et finalement la capacité de
s'exprimer à titre totalement individuel
une âme de fronde mais pour quel
résultat la gauche exclut de voter le
projet de loi immigration la droite
menace avec une motion de censure de
quoi mettre la pagaille dans la majorité
alors Sacha houiller jusqu'où irez-vous
voilà réponse à shaoli vous allez
continuer à fonder jusqu'à l'adoption du
texte parce qu'en réalité ce qu'on a vu
on a vu des questions européennes sur
l'immigration et on a aussi des réponses
nationales il répond nationale c'est de
lever des hypocrisies qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui en France on a des
difficultés à ce que des personnes qui
commettent des actes de délinquance sur
le territoire ne soient pas expulsés
c'est le fait que elle ne se passe
systématiquement expulsable c'est
l'objet d'une des dispositions de projet
de loi des répressif qui est
radicalement à droite et qui devrait
pouvoir être défendu parce que elle est
admise par la droite elle est soutenue
par les Français mais vous avez dit
après vous aviez la garantie que la
partie sur les régularisations des
métiers en tension serait dans le texte
c'est sûr ça et donc j'en viens à cette
deuxième partie pour lequel je réitère
le fait que j'ai eu des garanties
qu'elle soit dans le texte qui est elle
radicalement à gauche qui revient à dire
tous ceux qui sont aujourd'hui dans les
cuisines françaises qui assure la
propreté des bureaux qui sont dans les
hôpitaux de médecins à aide-soignant
pour
accompagner tous les personnes qui s'y
rendre ou dans les EHPAD pour prendre
soin de papiers ou mamie et ben toutes
ces personnes là quand elles sont depuis
plus de 3 ans sur le territoire qu'elles
ont travaillé 8 mois au minimum sur les
24 derniers mois elle mérite des papiers
c'est un projet qui est radicalement à
droite radicalement à gauche qu'il est
toutes les hypocrisies et moi je suis
prêt à beaucoup d'efforts pour que on
parvienne à faire ce que les Français
veulent parce que c'est toutes ces
mesures sont très populaires en même
temps macroniens sur l'immigration c'est
un fait vous dites que vous avez cette
garantie pourtant dans l'entourage des
Gérald Darmanin c'est c'est moins clair
l'idée de faire passer ce volet métier
en tension par circulaire n'est pas
complètement écarté si c'était le cas
votre est contre le projet de loi
d'abord moi je veux bien qu'on prenne
beaucoup de mots à Gérald Darmanin mais
c'est lui qui l'a mis dans le projet de
loi donc c'est aussi une discussion
qu'on a eu ensemble dès le départ sur le
fait qu'il y avait une nécessité à
légiférer vous lui faites confiance pour
faire c'était ça c'est l'homme de la
situation bah en tout cas c'est le
ministre de l'intérieur qu'à la charge
des négociations et donc moi j'ai toute
la confiance sur le fait que on a
travaillé ensemble ce texte tous ces
mesures sont une nécessité et donc on
doit les faire adopter par rapport à
pourquoi il faut que ce soit dans la loi
et pourquoi on le fait pas par une
mesure du gouvernement le prendre et
réglementaire et bien parce que
précisément aujourd'hui on a une
circulaire qui est non contraignante que
pour plein de raisons on applique pas on
applique mal donc on n'a pas de
résultats et donc des personnes qui sont
éligibles et qui devraient avoir des
papiers et qu'on devrait laisser
tranquille parce qu'elle travaille pour
le bien-être pays elle ne les ont pas
c'est pour ça qu'il faut une méthode
ou rien sinon vous votreez contre on est
bien d'accord pour l'instant j'ai pas
besoin de faire ce genre de ménage vous
avez parlé de coups de pression au
départ je pense qu'on a un travail de
co-construction qui fait qu'on aboutit à
ce texte là et donc mon travail moi
c'est d'aller chercher l'adhésion de
certains partis politiques on a vu
Gérald Darmanin qui était aux
universités du groupe liotte moi aussi
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec le groupe
cute on a eu des discussions quoi qu'on
en dise avec les républicains y compris
moi et puis on a des discussions avec
les groupes de gauche et donc
nécessairement moi puisque j'ai
peut-être plus indiqué pour ce on va
revenir au Républicain parce que les
lignes rouges n'ont pas n'ont pas
beaucoup bougé pour pour
bien quelles sont ces métiers en tension
on parle de la restauration de l'hôtel
riz on parle aussi de l'hôpital de la
santé mais on ne dit jamais combien
est-ce que vous avez une idée du nombre
de sans-papiers qui travaillent
aujourd'hui dans ces métiers là et
est-ce que la loi elle parle du stock
c'est-à-dire c'est sans papier qui sont
déjà là qui travaillent ou du flux c'est
à dire ce qui viendrait demain pour
travailler d'abord je vais être très
clair c'est le stock on parle
aujourd'hui des gens qui sont présents
sur le territoire et donc tous ceux qui
évoquent l'idée d'un appel d'air se
trompe parce que précisément c'est des
gens qui travaillent déjà on leur
demande trois dans un 3 ans d'ancienneté
on leur demande huit mois sur 24 et en
plus c'est une mesure qui est
expérimentale et qui expirera au bout de
plusieurs années donc ça ça c'est très
clair charge à nous de la reconduire
c'est la fonctionner ensuite normalement
devrait avoir totalement fonctionné on
n'aurait pas besoin de la Recon ensuite
sur la question de combien de personnes
ça représente
à priori pas là-dessus entre quelques
milliers et quelques dizaines de
milliers mais je vais être très précis
on ne sait pas et j'aimerais bien savoir
et donc j'aimerais bien demander à la
direction générale des étrangers en
France qui me le disent le service du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui concernait
en tout cas contrairement à d'autres
pays qui le font l'Allemagne va
nationaliser on fait pas ça on
régularise on donne des cartes de séjour
pas la nationalité l'Allemagne va
nationaliser un million de personnes la
Wallonie va massivement régulariser
l'Italie de Jordy Amélie on a vu tout à
l'heure les difficultés malgré ça
Georgia Meloni dont on peut pas la
suspecter de sympathie gauchistes elle
va régulariser 400 000 travailleurs sans
papier dans son pays ça n'est pas
l'option du gouvernement de la
régularisation c'est bien on est bien
au-delà de 10 fois moins alors juste une
petite question sur le Medef moi je
m'étonne de sa discrétion je croyais que
c'était si important pour les chefs
d'entreprise de parvenir assez
régularisation rapidement écouter un
allié ou pas les chefs d'entreprise y
compris adhérents au MEDEF à la KPM à la
FFB dans tous les syndicats
professionnels ils sont peut-être
discrets encore que ils prennent la
parole dans les médias locaux il y en a
beaucoup qui ont répondu à l'appel que
j'ai lancé à l'appel que à relayé
Stéphane séjourné auprès des chaises et
en tout cas ils sont dans nos
permanences pour nous dire nos salariés
ne nous les enlevez pas voilà ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui dans nos entreprises et
qui nous permettent de faire tourner les
boutiques ne nous les retirez pas une
autre tactique parlementaire serait de
scinder le texte en deux un projet de
loi et précis un projet de loi sur les
régularisations mais qui en tension ça
vous irait peu importe le flacon pourvu
qu'on est l'ivresse on a on a des
mesures qui sont nécessaires qui sont
importantes et qui sont je répète
populaire parce que soutenu par la
population et donc si c'est un texte si
c'est deux textes y compris même s'il
faut avoir une 49-3 parce que le
Parlement ne veut pas prendre ses
responsabilités il faut ces dispositions
80% des Français sont d'accord avec les
expulsions des étrangers délinquants 60%
des Français sont d'accord pour
régulariser les travailleurs dans les
médiateurs
si les parlementaires à un moment donné
ne sont pas capables de de reconnaître
des mesures qui auront été intense
soutenus par la partie sans jamais avoir
été mis en place c'est Nicolas Sarkozy
qui avait supprimé à double peine c'est
la gauche qui n'a jamais légiférée sur
la régularisation dont je vous parle et
bien je pense que sur ce sujet il faut
que nous prenions les nôtres bon la
route est longue le texte arrive début
novembre au Sénat il y a eu pas mal de
rebondissements quelque chose me dit
qu'il y en aura sûrement d'autres
l'autre l'autre sujet sur lequel la
majorité est plus qu'attendue c'est le
pouvoir d'achat Bruno Le Maire a reçu
les distributeurs les pompistes qui
vendent de l'essence dans les stations
services revendre à perte vous croyez
qu'ils vont le faire vraiment je le
pense d'autant plus que ce sera permis
de pas la loi ce que je vais vous dire
par rapport à ça c'est que surtout tout
ce qui est le quotidien des Français
dans les dernières années dans les 12
derniers mois il y a une action du
gouvernement sur le carburant il y a eu
la remise à la pompe aujourd'hui il y a
la vente à perte qui permet d'économiser
jusqu'à 47 centimes d'euros 47 centimes
vous sortez d'où ce chiffre
qui nous a été transmise par le
gouvernement et a priori leur leur
logiciel qui permettent des simulations
sont plutôt exactes puisque c'est ceux
qui tu as envie de calculer 30 centimes
de réduction deuxième chose sur
l'électricité le gaz je veux quand même
rappeler que certes elle a augmenté pour
de nombreux Français et c'est douloureux
quand on regarde les factures en
revanche elle a été très largement
limitée cette augmentation par le
bouclier tarifaire y compris financé
parce qu'on a fait la taxe sur les
supers profits finalement on a découvert
ce que c'était on a fait la taxe sur les
super profit elle a rapporté 26
milliards d'euros et c'est C26 milliards
d'euros qui ont permis et bien que les
Français ne payent pas beaucoup plus
cher et la gaz électricité troisième
chose sur les prix de l'alimentaire vous
souvenez qu'il y a eu le trimestre
anti-inflation donc on a réussi à
contenir les prix maintenant les prix
sont contenus à la hausse donc ce qu'on
fait ce qu'on veut faire c'est faire une
loi qui permet de renégocier les prix
pour qu'il soit aujourd'hui à la baisse
l'inflation qui commence à stagner voir
baisser les Français ne le ressort pas
je voudrais vous montrer votre collègue
Richard Amos du MoDem qui lui propose
sur les questions des sens de revenir à
ce qu'on appelle la tcpe flottante et
donc en gros de baisser les taxes quand
le baril est bien augmente pourquoi pas